some headphones and
and and equipment and everything but
football is getting spiked yesterday for
big ten and pac-12 fans
the uh
college football continues to be the top
story for the nfl because the nfl needs
to know what's going on we all need to
know what's going on with college
football yep the big ten and the pac-12
postponed their seasons on
tuesday
but at a time when two of the power five
conferences decide to wait until spring
at the earliest sec in acc not canceling
the seasons yet chris and look they may
have to at some point they may have to
eventually surrender to their inability
to contain and control the virus on a
conference wide scale maybe one school
can another school can't right then they
start intermingling and it becomes an
outbreak type of a situation but for now
sec
and acc plan to go forward the one
that's kind of hanging out there is the
big 12 right i don't know how much of a
swing it really is does does the if the
big 12 decides to postpone does that get
the acc and the sec to stand down i
don't know let's look at what some of
the powers that b had to say though big
ten commissioner kevin warren and i
think this is an important statement
from him it became abundantly clear that
there was too much uncertainty regarding
potential medical risks to allow student
athletes to compete this fall chris that
gets back to the concern that there may
be some long-term heart problems right
associated with the covet 19 infection
that people don't understand enough
about so if you play and you expose your
players to those risks you're
potentially going to be on the hook from
a liability standpoint for exposing them
to the risks and having those heart
problems develop later yeah well i think
you know what you're seeing there from a
guy like kevin warren he's doesn't want
that on his conscience he doesn't want
to deal with that and put people you
know in a spot where they could struggle
for the rest of their life and yes
there's so much unknown still this is
still you know early stages of this
virus and what it does to you long term
even like the short long term we're
still not even sure about that so yeah i
mean to me it goes that back to that and
short long term does that make sense i
know it but it's fine but but also i
always think of the liability aspect not
not to be confused the short term long
short time the short term long short
term short long term i'm not sure which
is which i think you've got taking those
parking options at the airport i'm not
sure which one is cheaper yeah short
long term or long short term but either
way it's in between you got my point uh
but yeah i think you know between that
and then mike i mean i go back to
something you've said you're smarter
than me and you kind of said this right
from the start you know the the future
liability concerns that that's real i
gotta think that's you know in the
brains of some of these guys who maybe
have a little bit better you know
business acumen as far as what to expect
and and everything like that and i'm
sure that scares you know the powers
that be in the pac-12 and the big ten
and it's important to set this up the
right way because we now have the
ammunition to do so we have kevin
warren's statement where he referenced
potential medical risks to allow the
student athlete to compete in the fall
oregon president michael schill our
decision was guided by science and a
deep commitment to the health and safety
and welfare of our student athletes and
then comes the sec commissioner greg
sankey
saying in his statement i look forward
to learning more about the factors that
led the big 10 and the pac-12 leadership
to take these actions today yes
you should
learn more about the factors because
here's the problem now chris if the acc
and the sec and possibly the big 12.
there was a report last night the big 12
intends to go forward but you know i
intend to do a lot of things and i'm not
eventually going to do it it's one thing
to say we want to do it it's another
thing to actually do it if two or three
of these conferences go forward in the
fall
and there is some sort of litigation
that emerges if players become ill if
players family members who are infected
by the player become ill or die
one of the arguments and it may not even
have to be spoken it may just kind of
hover over the litigation and ultimately
hover over the courtroom and eventually
infiltrate the jury room
the mere fact that two
major college football conferences
decided it wasn't safe right to go
forward
maybe all you need when it's time to
check the box on the verdict form yeah
for responsible or not responsible
guilty or not guilty right liable or not
liable hey
the big ten in the pac-12 realized it's
not safe
and
this lawsuit the fact that these
individuals who have brought this
litigation were sickened or worse by the
virus
and it can be traced to the fact that
these colleges decided to go forward in
the sec and the acc and maybe the big
12.
it makes it a hell of a lot easier
to lose yeah and lose big right and and
and we don't it's this unknown liability
you don't know how many people are going
to come to the table we don't and this
is what we talked about yesterday and
i've seen some feedback from people who
don't really understand the legal system
and some people who think they do
just because and we and let's be clear
on this you know the typical negligence
lawsuit you have to show
failure to comply with a reasonably
prudent standard of care you know
somebody doing something stupid that
that lays the foundation
but you have to connect somebody doing
something they shouldn't have done
to the injury that happens and causation
is the key
proximate causation is the buzzword in
the legal system but i could see the law
as it relates to covert 19 evolving to
the point
where because this thing is everywhere
you're not required to show
that you actually caught it
going to this football practice
participating in this game bringing it
home to that family member that chain i
don't think is going to be as demanding
as it is in other cases and i think it's
going to be enough by the time these
different courts in different states and
different jurisdictions understand
what's fair and just
hey you set up a spreading event without
the proper safeguards at a time when you
should have known
that you are exposing people to this
risk and we're not going to require the
person who got sick because they
participated in your activity to prove
that they didn't get it anywhere else
yeah if you can prove they got it
somewhere else fine that's that's an
affirmative defense but
you won't have to prove that you got it
there as the person that's you know
doing the accusing that's that would be
just my question to you there
if if i'm kevin warren yeah the big ten
commissioner if i'm the pac-12
commissioner if i'm the president of any
of these universities if i'm anyone in
any position to care about the long-term
balance sheets of these organizations i
am factoring in the possibility that by
the time it's all said and done yeah
that person
who
showed up for this event that can be
proven doesn't meet the reasonable
safety standards that should have been
in place yeah that you're not going to
have to show that the molecule entered
my nose or my eye because i was there
because how in the hell are you ever
going to prove that yeah right right
right are you going to prove that yeah
so i i think that's why and and look
it you here here's the thing here wait
one more thing here's the thing let me
just say let me just say one thing i
think it's funny i think it's funny that
non-lawyers and lawyers alike who think
they understand how this all is going to
play out believe that they can convince
the commissioners and the presidents to
not worry about it simply because
they're saying so on social media that
part of it's funny to me anyway go ahead
yeah no it is but okay so here's a
question for you all right because this
is
totally spitballing not even trying to
go political here at all but there is
some crossover so i gotta hit it here
now
you know
the guidelines the things that are put
in place all right you're talking about
the things that you and i know that you
know certainly seems somewhat common
sense right now to stop the spread of
the virus and all that
that hasn't necessarily been relayed to
the rest of the country
okay and
where i where i get into this is we have
leadership you know the president and
other people who are certainly saying
other things
would that bolster the cases of the sec
and acc to be like listen we know the
cdc might be saying this but the
president said that would that legally
help them you know that that's no no you
don't think so because
look here's eventually right there will
be crafted a standard of what was
expected yeah okay what was a school
expected to do what was a business
expected to do
and
you will be expected to have cut through
the fog and made reasonably prudent
decisions on how to properly take care
of the people who are entrusted to your
care and that's where the duty may be
even a little bit higher it's one thing
you know to say we have a business
that's open whoever wants to come can
come it's another thing to say we've got
a school where these these kids come
here and they are you know entrusted to
our care i mean so but regardless of
that because i don't want to get too far
into the shifting duties that may apply
right but
there will eventually be a standard
and and it may be one standard in
california one standard in texas that's
yeah right or there could be a national
standard as to what you have to show but
usually what happens
cases like this get resolved and
determined one at a time and the
precedent from one case becomes relevant
to the next case and through that
one case after another case after
another case you develop a body of law
that lawyers
that that's what we do we we try to
understand what that is and we try to
figure out whether or not the facts of a
given case fit within that precedent
it's a very complicated
ugly process where it's not nearly as
formulaic as you would think there's no
calculator you use and it's all
determined one case at a time but i
could see over time
you know and you still see
commercials on tv for asbestos
litigation right that's been hanging
around forever you know every once in a
while you find this one thing that
explodes
into a nationwide
you know industry of lawsuits and you
know whether it's the weed eater cases
that you see that advertised on tv i
mean this could become
a huge huge subset of the broader legal
industry you've been ripped off i think
that's a virus call florio and florio
but but like but now listen i don't want
to make light of it because this is this
is serious from a business standpoint
it's a serious from an individual
standpoint and and and let me just make
this point
because this leads into another angle
that could solve the problem for some of
these colleges in one fell swoop
the legal system is there to put guard
rails on what american business would
otherwise do
and people like to complain about
lawyers and the legal system and every
frivolous lawsuit is the lawsuit that
was filed against me right um
that that's the reaction yeah anytime
someone gets sued they say it's
frivolous no look
you put those guard rails on what
businesses are allowed to do and not do
and it forces them to be safe and
prudent and to give a crap about their
fellow man right because there's a price
tag if you don't give a crap about your
fellow man sure you take those guard
rails off chris yeah who the hell knows
what happens and then and then you're at
the mercy yeah of the ethics or lack
thereof of somebody who looks at it and
says well we could do it this way and it
would be safe
or we could do it this way and we could
save a hell of a lot of money yeah right
let's do it this way right there's no
reason to not do it this way let's do it
this way these and it's easy with the
cover 19. they all know the risks they
all know when they leave their house
they could get it why are we worried
about it go ahead have that game have
that season have that practice have this
have that anybody who shows up they know
what they're getting themselves into and
if they don't want they can stay home
and hide under the bed so and i and i
say that chris because there's a push in
some states well yeah provide immunity
immunity right so you can't get sued
well that's what i'm saying
conversation
no not well before we even get to the
waiver yeah cause the waiver's not going
anywhere yeah the thing that college
football players need to be concerned
about is immunity because if the
government comes in and says you can't
sue it doesn't matter if you signed a
waiver or not you can't sue right the
guard rails are gone right we're giving
it we're giving them a a favor here
we're taking the guard rails off yeah
yeah yeah that's it so that could happen
right
that's uh that's an interesting aspect
certainly well you know i think the you
know that plays into this you know
specific scenario though
is
acc sec certainly mostly
states that
seem to be a little bit more forgiving
when it comes to the pandemic or you
know whatever you want to say but
certainly not as strict as far as what
we have learned from the cdc guidelines
and all those type of things yeah that's
that's been going down in that part so
maybe those are states that will back
that up i mean we brought this up
yesterday but you know again the the old
miss governor didn't say anything about
masks until he realized there might not
be college football and he said i want
everybody to start wearing masks because
i want to watch college football this
year so that just tells you the state of
mind and of course that is a huge part
of the culture down there and i
understand that money is playing into
this and everything like that
there is a lot of aspects here but yeah
you got to do it safe you got to do it
right i don't know mike i mean you know
i will say this i'm continuing to be
encouraged by of course the bubble
leagues and and
basketball at hockey but you know major
league baseball not a bubble doing
pretty damn well the nfl certainly seems
i know we have cardinals yeah well yeah
except the cardinals right but you know
then the nfl i think things are looking
pretty good so far too i know we haven't
started tackling and hitting and doing
all that but you know those should be
things i do think the sec and acc could
look at to go wait they're managing this
they're making it somewhat you know
doable and let's see where it goes um
i'm not saying it's right or wrong but
you know there's there's some examples
out there of it going in the right
direction at least
here's the kinds of things that you may
hear from various states and this was a
quote recently from tennessee lieutenant
governor randy mcnally a republican from
oak ridge i think i heard the last thing
small business owners pastors doctors
and school superintendents need to worry
about her frivolous lawsuits which would
further impede their ability to do their
jobs yeah in this difficult time well
okay but what about the lawsuits that
have merit that's the thing
you you you enter into this immunity
discussion under the guise of saying we
don't want these organizations to be the
subject of frivolous lawsuits but you
take off the guard rails you let them do
whatever they want right and you're
wiping out the possibility of
merit-based lawsuits being potentially
filed to get
fair compensation when someone does
something they shouldn't have done yeah
like the employer left five guys in the
in the door that day that have coven 19
he just says i don't care then somebody
comes down with it and yeah you're in
your scenario there you're saying small
business is going to be protected and
that's not right because he's being
careless and of course endangering other
people
well consider the grocery stores that
are are
even though and and i know people are
going to think this is political but
it's ridiculous to call it political
it's it's factual you know if you would
try to walk into a grocery store without
a shirt on or without shoes on or
carrying an open container or beer
they'd tell you to get the hell out yeah
you walk in without a mask on even if
it's mandated in the local jurisdiction
they won't say anything to you yeah you
walk in and the mask is hanging down
under your nose they won't say anything
to you you're you know going down the
aisle and you decide you've had enough
of the mask for now and you pull it down
under your chin which i think is funny
like hey i have a mask i just don't
happen to have it my mouth in my nose
right nobody says anything to you and uh
you know that that's
having
having that potential for liability is
the kind of thing that gets businesses
to choose
short-term doing the right thing
because long-term they may end up with a
major problem so we'll see how that
plays out and you mentioned the the
concept of waiver yeah and and
you know we've seen people in the media
and there are people in the media who
want college football to go forward
because they want college football to go
forward for their own selfish interests
suggesting the idea that college
football players should just sign a
waiver just sign away your rights that's
the flip side to immunity hey just sign
away your rights just do whatever you
have to do put your name on the bottom
of on the bottom line so you can't sue
and go ahead and step into that petri
dish of cove 19 and give it to your
grandma and maybe grandma dies uh it's
amazing to me
that number one people who are
affiliated with major networks would
make that argument number two the major
networks would let them it's the height
of your responsibility to pressure kids
into signing a waiver the only good news
is the ncaa said last week there will be
no waivers signed by student athletes at
our member institutions yeah period good
well i think that's safe they got to do
their job and to protect these kids and
you know as everything you've just said
you know there's just so much unknown
and and yeah you know there could be
that day where and i'm not rooting for
this and surely hoping never happens but
yeah that some football player does get
covered 19 and it has you know the bad
long-term effects somewhere six seven
years down the road we start to learn
that you know covet 19 did this to the
nervous system or did this to the brain
you know and then we're gonna go oh well
you signed a waiver sorry you know so
okay yeah it's unknown right now so the
ncaa good for them for protecting the
players a little bit in this in this
case
isn't it amazing that one of the saddest
footnotes of this crazy time we live in
is that it's now perfectly acceptable
to point a finger at someone who dares
to engage in
the attempt to apply foresight to a
situation
and identify worst-case scenarios as
someone who is actually rooting for the
worst case scenarios to happen that
we're only mentioning this because we
want to see it all burn that is beyond
ridiculous it is a sad statement as to
where we've arrived as a society right
that those who would bother to say hang
on a second
there may be a problem
with this
right
there may be an issue here
that those people just get ignored and
get shouted down it's like the guy in
jurassic park who's the guy
the guy that jeff goldblum whatever
character he was in jurassic park that's
right the guy trying to tell him how to
control life these dinosaurs yeah these
dinosaurs are gonna eat everybody
eventually right and i'm not saying it
because i want to see people get eaten
by dinosaurs i'm saying it because i
hope to avoid that outcome
right that's what and and now if you do
that as it relates to covert 19 people
think you just want to see college
football burn and the nfl burn and
people get covered 19 so we can say i
told you so it's ridiculous chris
it's exhausting well it it just you know
as you said it feeds into what our
country is right now you know the and i
you know the narcissism you know fed by
social media and everybody being a
know-it-all and everything like that
yeah we've lost our way that way it's
where our country's been flipped upside
down you know i i hope we can straighten
it out but you're right it's all about
you know me me me me me me my thought my
thought by thought my thought it's more
important i know i know i know i'm not a
doctor i've never been in the hospital
before but i'm going to tell you how you
should a you know you should approach
the coronavirus you know hey chris sims
i've never seen an nfl football player
in person before but i'm telling you
this quarterback's better than that
quarterback i've never seen one in
person and i don't know anything about
it and i'm a plumber but i'm gonna tell
you you're a stupid idiot when four
letter words and blah blah blah
and your family sucks but your rankings
suck and that's just the way we are
right now and it's insane it's insane
i remember when i was a kid and i first
became aware of this saying eat drink
and be merry for tomorrow we shall die
and i thought that is incredibly morbid
right yeah but you know what
i
that that attitude is what's driving all
of this just do what you want today
we'll worry about tomorrow tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports